POLITICAL INTERFERENCE.
>> Jason: HERE FOR A A
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" EXCLUSIVE,
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
AND, THE COMMUNITIES ARE SO
TIGHTLY KNIT.
LOTS OF FARMING ACTIVITY GOING
ON HERE.
AND GARCIA WAS ACCUSED AND
REMIND VIEWERS WHAT HAPPENED
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> THAT WAS ONLY 12 OFFICERS,
AND THIS WAS REALLY A TRAGEDY
FOR THE VALLEY.
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN HERE MANY
TIMES.
AND IT'S NOT EXACTLY THE WAY
THAT WE WANT TO SPEND THEIR
HOLIDAYS.
SO RIGHT BEFORE CHRISTMAS, WE
HAD A VERY SIMILAR SITUATION
WHERE THERE WAS SOMEONE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND HAD BEEN
DEPORTED TWICE, AND HAD BEEN
ARRESTED JUST PRIOR AND WAS
RELEASED BECAUSE OF THE
SANCTUARY CITY LAW.
THEY COULDN'T HOLD IT GARCIA WHO
WENT ON A RAMPAGE FOR OVER
24 HOURS.
KILLED TWO PEOPLE, POSSIBLY A
THIRD.
WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE I THINK
THERE IS STILL ONE IN CRITICAL
CONDITION IN THE HOSPITAL.
BECAUSE THIS PERSON, GARCIA WENT
AROUND THE ENTIRE COUNTY TO
SEVERAL COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
SHOOTING PEOPLE AT RANDOM.
STEALING VEHICLES AND FINALLY
CAUSED A MAJOR TRAFFIC ACCIDENT,
AND THE CAR EXPLODED, AND HE IS
NOW NO LONGER A PART OF THE
PLANET.
THE BAD PART IS, THERE ARE TWO
INNOCENTS THAT LOST THEIR LIVES,
JUST LIKE WHAT WE EXPERIENCE THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS JUST NORTH OF
HERE IN NEWMAN, WHERE HE WE HAD
A POLICE OFFICER THAT WAS
KILLED.
IT WAS A HORRIBLE SITUATION, AND
THE LAST ELECTION IN CALIFORNIA,
THESE POLICIES WERE REWARDED AT
THE BALLOT BOX.
SO THE DEMOCRATS WHO CONDONE
THESE POLICIES PROBABLY HAD
THEIR BIGGEST ELECTION WIN EVER.
SO SOMETHING IS NOT MAKING
SENSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE JUST
AREN'T GETTING THE RIGHT
INFORMATION, THAT YOU WOULD
THINK AT SOME POINT POLITICIANS
WOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS OR INACTIONS, AND
IN THIS CASE IT'S PRETTY DARN
CLEAR THAT THESE SANCTUARY CITY
POLICIES ARE LEADING TO INNOCENT
GETTING MURDERED.
>> Jason: WHILE THAT'S THE
SITUATION WITH GARCIA, THE ONE
THAT HAPPENED LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS AGO, ESSENTIALLY IN YOUR
BACKYARD.
THIS PERSON I BELIEVE HAD BEEN
INCARCERATED BEFORE AND SERVED
TIME FOR ARMED ROBBERY, HE HAD
BEEN DEPORTED TWICE, AND STILL
HE IS IN THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT NO
COMMUNICATION AND HE'S ABLE TO
COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO INFURIATING
BECAUSE BOTH OF THESE CASES, AT
LEAST ON THE SURFACE OR THE
INFORMATION WE HAD NOW COME UP
BOTH OF THESE WERE PREVENTABLE,
WHERE THEY NOT?
>> NO QUESTION.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE IT'S
EVEN WORSE, THE SITUATION HERE
IN OUR HOME COUNTY IS THAT THIS
PERSON HAD ACTUALLY BEEN
DEPORTED TWICE.
SO THAT'S THE WHOLE CHALLENGE
HERE, THAT THINGS AREN'T ADDING
UP.
A LOT OF THE CALIFORNIA BORDER
ACTUALLY HAS FENCING ON IT.
SO THE KEY HERE IS, WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO DO IN CONGRESS
AND WITH THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TRYING TO DO, I THINK A VERY
LOGICAL SOLUTION WHICH IS, LET'S
TAKE THE AREAS THAT WE HAVE SOME
FENCING WHICH ISN'T QUITE
WORKING, LET'S BUILD A WALL, ONE
THAT ACTUALLY WORKS, AND THOSE
POPULATED AREAS AND LET'S MAKE
SURE WE GET THOSE SECURE, FIRST.
AND THOSE OTHER AREAS YOU MAY
NOT NEED A WALL OR FENCING.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PRESIDENT
WAS VERY REASONABLE AND WAS ABLE
TO SOLVE THE DACA PROBLEM.
WE HAD A VOTE IN CONGRESS WHERE
REPUBLICANS VOTED TO BUILD A
WALL AND REFORM DACA, TAKE CARE
OF THE KIDS THROUGH NO PART OF
THEIR OWN.
WE DIDN'T GET ONE DEMOCRATIC
VOTE.
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VOTED AGAINST THIS
LAW.
THOSE ARE FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO LIVE HERE THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN MADE LEGAL, BUT FOR SOME
REASON, PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY DON'T REALIZE, A
SENSIBLE SOLUTION WAS PUT ON THE
TABLE.
BORDER SECURITY PUT IN FOR DACA,
A PERMIT SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE HERE TO DO JOBS THAT AREN'T
GOING TO BE FILLED FOR AMERICAN
AMERICANS.
SENSIBLE SOLUTIONS THAT JUST
AREN'T BEING COMMUNICATED TO THE
PEOPLE AND I THINK THEY ARE
MAKING SOME UNINFORMED
DECISIONS.
>> Jason: IT'S AMAZING THAT
DACA WAS PUT ON THE TABLE AND
DEMOCRATS REJECT THAT.
BUT I WANT TO PLAYER CLIP, THAT
SEEMS THAT DEMOCRATS ARE AGAINST
THIS BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP IS FOR
IT.
IT DOESN'T SEEMS TOO LONG AGO
THAT CHUCK SCHUMER ACTUALLY
BELIEVED IN A BORDER WALL, WATCH
THIS.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF OUR EFFORTS
IN CONGRESS, OUR BORDER IS FAR
MORE SECURE TODAY THAN IT WAS
WHEN WE BEGAN DEBATING
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM IN 2005.
BETWEEN 2005 AND 2009, A VAST
AMOUNT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
ON OUR BORDERS AND PORTS OF
ENTRY.
THE PROGRESS INCLUDES 9,000 NEW
BORDER PATROL FIELD AGENTS IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
CONSTRUCTION OF A 630-MILE
BORDER FENCE, OR 630 MILES OF
BORDER FENCE THAT CREATE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ON A SOUTHERN LAND
BORDER.
>> THERE YOU GO, I COULD PLAY
THAT ALL DAY LONG.
HE VOTED TO AUTHORIZE IT, BUT
NOW, HE WON'T VOTE IN FAVOR OF
ACTUALLY FUNDING IT.
NOW, THE WE ONLY HAVE A MINUTE
LEFT BUT NANCY PELOSI IS IN
HAWAII.
MAXINE WATERS IS OFF VACATIONING
IN THE BAHAMAS.
YOU ARE IN YOUR DISTRICT, KEVIN
McCARTHY WHO IS FROM THE
BAKERSFIELD AREA IS AT HOME IN
HIS DISTRICT.
HOW DOES THE PRESIDENT COME TO A
RESOLUTION WHEN NANCY PELOSI IS
WORKING ON HER HULA AS OPPOSED
TO ACTUALLY NEGOTIATING
SOMETHING THAT'S REASONABLE?
WHERE DOES THIS GO?
>> I'M RIGHT HERE IN TULARE
TULARE COUNTY, AND IT DOESN'T
GET BETTER THAN THIS, RIGHT HERE
IN THE AGRICULTURE MUSEUM.
IF I WAS IN HAWAII RIGHT NOW, I
WOULD BE GETTING KILLED IF KEVIN
McCARTHY, THE NEW REPUBLICAN
LEADER, WAS IN HAWAII RIGHT NOW.
HE WOULD BE GETTING CRUSHED.
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT AND
WASHINGTON, D.C., EACH WAITING
TO CUT A DEAL AND THEY ARE ON
VACATION.
THEY NEVER WANTED TO SHUT DOWN
AND THE SECOND THAT DONALD TRUMP
SAID I WILL OWN THE SHUTDOWN, OR
I'LL SHUT IT DOWN, THEY SAID,
I'LL GET OUT OF TOWN AND GO TO
HAWAII.
YOU WATCH ON JANUARY 3RD WHEN
THERE'S A NEW CONGRESS, THEY
WILL TRY TO PASS SOMETHING AND
THIS WILL JUST CONTINUE.
IN THE MEANTIME, PROBLEMS ARE
NOT BEING SOLVED.
THE GOOD NEWS IS ABOUT ALL THIS,
NOW THEY WILL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PUT
LEGISLATION ON THE FLOOR THAT
WILL FIX THESE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN UNWILLING TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS OR SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA TO FIX.
>> Jason: CONGRESSMAN, THANKS
FOR YOUR GREAT WORK.
I DO THINK THE DEMOCRATS WANT
THE ISSUE MORE THAN THEY WANT TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
I ALSO WISHED THE SENATE WOULD
VOTE ON THE BILL THE HOUSE
PASSED.
REMEMBER THE HOUSE TO PASS THE
$5 BILLION, IT'S THE SENATE
THAT'S NOT DOING IT.
AND I PLEAD WITH THE MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE SENATE, PUT THEM
ON THE RECORD, MAKE THEM
ACTUALLY VOTE.
SEE WHO ACTUALLY STANDS FOR THE
BORDER AND WHO DOESN'T.
YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT BY ACTUALLY
HOLDING A VOTE BECAUSE, THE END